we have this from cnr.com Trump ordered
to pay 83.3 million in Damages to eege
Carroll our legal system is out of
control and being used as a political
weapon the former president said in
response now Trump has repeatedly said
he never met this woman many on social
media have pointed out that her story
about Trump is the plot to an episode of
Law and Order
SVU yeah you yeah no it was it was um it
was similar to a plot that was in a in
in a Law and Order
not saying she got it from there
but kinky dinky is it and then we have
this from Nikki Haley who tweets yeah
Donald Trump wants to be the presumptive
Republican nominee and we're talking
about $83 million in Damages we're not
talking about fixing the Border we're
not talking about tackling inflation
America can do better than Donald Trump
and Joe Biden let me tell you what Nikki
Haley is doing here first Donald Trump
issued a statement saying he does not
want to be the presumptive Nomine he
wants to win legitimately and and these
These primar are actually good for him
so she's lying there and then she is
taking an attack from Democrats to use
against the most popular Republican
right now this is disqualifying she's a
Democrat she's got Democrat donors
Democrat voters and she's using Democrat
tactics to try and go after Donald Trump
and using Larry Elder's tagline for
decades I've been saying we got a
country to save and I said it over and
over again during the campaign all of a
sudden Nikki Hill has been saying it we
got she's been ending her speeches with
we've got a country to save stole it
from the great urki I get no royalties I
get nothing great El DKI I love it and
if Donald Trump has to pay her $83
million why I should have sued the LA
time for defamation when I was called
the blackface of right Supremacy what
could I have gotten well this is what's
laughable nothing because we live in the
logic of Herbert M this is laughable I I
actually tweeted something at Frank Lun
because he was talking about it I'm just
like anybody who works in media and
journalism knows this is fake and any
journalist claiming otherwise is lying
to you why every journalist knows times
V Sullivan because every day you write
about someone it has you work you work
for LA Times oh wait sorry you work for
LA Times anymore uh you work for the New
York Times when you're writing a story
it's got to get checked by legal legal
has to the lawyer goes through and make
sure you're not in violation they all
are aware of defamation and Lial laws
and so here Donald Trump is being told
to pay $83 million he's not allowed to
say he didn't do it it's it's it's
remarkable but Trump said several times
in court when this going down this isn't
this is not America and the scary thing
is we are now in the in the world where
there is no law there's none there is
only left and right jury pools and good
luck and double standard you've got um
Navaro facing four months for defying a
subpoena meanwhile Eric Holder was the
first AG to be found in criminal
contempt of congress for failing to to
to supply to comply with a subpoena when
he was required to turn over documents
regarding Fast and Furious nothing
happened to him no I mean there's a
complete double standard even though I
mean even in this case if you read the
excerpt from Carol's book where she
accuses Donald Trump she says it was in
maybe the summer or maybe the fall but
maybe the spring she can't remember any
of the details she says the dress is
still hung in her closet like all of her
allegations are ridiculous on their face
and he's never been tried in a criminal
court right he has just been put through
Civil Trial he's never he's never been
allowed to defend himself he's never
been in fact he wasn't allowed to defend
himself when he was president just
speaking openly but she was allowed to
make allegations with no basis there's a
boatload of tweets that that the Trump
uh defense team wanted to submit that
were incredibly graphic and called into
question whether or not egene Carroll is
the kind of person that would be
considered promiscuous or you know just
really reliable um and they just said no
we can't you can't put them into it's a
complete double standard she was allowed
to be treated in a way that Donald Trump
was not allowed to be treated the
problem and Larry knows this just as
well as anyone else and it's something
that I harp on we live in the logic of
Herbert ACC we live in a society where
one political opinion is acceptable to
attack it is acceptable to uh to use the
government against one group of people
that have a certain political opinion it
is acceptable to be violent against them
it's acceptable to hit them it's AC take
their property dise you don't think that
that's the case that may have been 10
years ago but since the since the
culture War expanded the point where
we're at now with like budlight I think
it's now clear that institutions have no
problem espousing the ideology of their
side the issue with this is that Donald
Trump was sued in New York City where it
is a stronghold of Communists
jurisdiction does matter yes fair enough
Donald Trump should sue in West Virginia
where 86% of West Virginia are huge
Trump fans and the jury pool would be
like we are impartial Trump should sue
her for defamation in West Virginia the
question is why does he not if Trump
went to West Virginia and said oh I got
a house here I I'm suing her here he'd
win in two seconds he'd win 83.3 million
in fact he'd win simply because I
guarantee you you you you you pull a 100
West Virginia about this and they're
going to be pissed off not everybody's
going to know about it don't get me
wrong but if they know they're going to
be like they're doing what to Donald
Trump in fact you go to the W you go to
Western Maryland okay Maryland which is
you know Baltimore has basically got its
boot on it and we went to a we went to a
diner and they had flags of Donald Trump
riding a tank standing on a tank with
fireworks exploding and him holding like
an Uzi there's one of him on a
velociraptor and I'm like these people
love Donald Trump Donald sue her back
and do it here and sue her for defaming
you for claiming falsely how amazing
would it be you you could even do it in
the middle of California I talk about
this in my book I travel up and down the
state there large portions of that state
where they love Donald Trump I'm driving
I see big Trump signs the farmers love
him people in the middle of the St State
adore him it's people in the Bay Area in
San Diego and in La they're the problem
this is what we need right now we need
Donald Trump to sue egene Carroll in
West Virginia so that we get a default
verdict same as as however it is his
cases are going down where they say it
was false and defamatory that she
claimed Trump assaulted her and that she
has to pay him because of it so then New
York says no Trump did and then West
Virginia says no she lied and then there
you go the the issue right now what
you're bringing up Phil is that it's
true in the sense that if you are that
it's true that Democrats and their
institutions have no problem breaking
the rules and doing these things the
only issue is I don't see Trump filing a
lawsuit in W like Trump could just
choose to do it he's not yeah he's not
doing it I I have no no qual with what
you're saying and and I agree the
solution to this stuff is law fair you
know it it is to do bring as many
lawsuits against any politician any
organization that's left leaning
anything that you can come up with but
do you think that meant he would have
had to sue egene Carroll in 2019 when
she first released this book I have no
idea because I mean theoretically that
would have been the first way to set
president who car else he would have
been the president and they would have
freaked out but it doesn't matter
because what we're clearly seeing here
is lawfare this the the trial against
Trump for fraud in New York is clearly
false these claims are are ridiculous on
their face so if they're going to make I
mean look they they created a new law
where women could bring up old cases and
Sue over it or something like this so
that they could uh uh which case was
that was it was it egene Carroll where
she could claim that cuz I think this is
defamation this was not related to
sexual assault or I'm not talking about
her lobbying to change the laws in there
was a law that said you had a we're
going to introduce a one-year window
where people can Su I think it going
after Harvey Weinstein right okay was
that that was for I I if if they're
going to play this
game and all that really matters is a
judge is going to determine for some re
reason or another Trump is not allowed
to defend himself so let's look at the
fraud case the judge ruled uh in default
he said no Trump trump committed fraud
end of story have a nice day you can't
defend yourself they just bang the gavl
it's done okay well Trump go to West
Virginia and find someone who do the
exact same thing in the other other
direction there there there we go it's
the only way it's going to change or the
only only moves we can make and there a
bunch of Republican AGS who also could
figure out all sorts of ways to sue um
democrats for this that and the other
that's another thing that's mading is
there's plenty of Republican AGS they
should be they should be inundating
Democrat politicians for anything it
should be it should be No Holds Barred
law fair just as much as much litigation
as possible this is the way they want it
give it to them you know there's so many
double standards one of them is this
election denier stuff Hillary for four
years referred to Donald Trump as
illegitimate said the election was
stolen uh the did you see just the other
day when Biden said that the governor of
Virginia no governor of uh yeah Virginia
with with a real Governor yeah and you
had the uh the race in Georgia um uh
Stacy uh what's your last ABS yeah Stacy
Abrams claims that uh she lost because
of voter fraud uh Hillary for four years
referred to Donald Trump as illegitimate
four years and the AG DHS secretary
under Obama J Johnson testified under
oath not a single vote tally was changed
by the Russians they tried but they
failed to change a single vote tally 66%
of Democrats according to a yugov poll
believe the Russians change vot tties to
get Donald Trump elected Jimmy Carter
said it yeah yeah imagine the president
saying that election was stolen it is it
is in it is
Indescribable to to to try and explain
to people like what it's like trying to
to make people understand that that the
idea that like the conservatives are
living in a fantasy world and you hear
the the rhetoric coming out of the out
of like MSNBC and and CBS and all the
the the the you know the the standard
narrative producing uh organizations
smear Merchants whenever whenever I said
push back and go well well Hillary
didn't file a lawsuit yes she did she
joined the lawsuit that Jill Stein filed
against uh Wisconsin and filed a
separate motion to have the recall
recount done by hand well Hillary didn't
didn't storm the capital people on
January 6th because she wasn't president
but Donald Trump got elected in November
there were 40 cities where there were
protests including violent protests
police cars set on fire in DC hundreds
were arrested and get this not only were
there hundreds of people setting fires
smashing things that that was at the at
the inauguration at the inauguration the
city actually paid the the riers the
city paid the riers out yeah there were
two or 300 of them as I recall but I'm
talking about when Donald Trump got
elected there were 40 cities where there
were violent protest all over including
setting fire to police station my point
is had Hillary been president and the
she were on the other foot and the
election was this questionable you're
telling me that her supporters would
said oh well let's rub some donut we'll
get you're saying Barack Obama engaged
in
Insurrection Barack Obama and get waged
Insurrection in what way well he was
president when all of his supporters
went out and started burning things that
clearly
means I don't recall Donald Trump saying
to be violent or storm anything in fact
I Rec Trum saying he he said I want you
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices
heard said that that the people that
were out in the streets should be spec
she that verbatim and they should be
they're not going to she was saying
they're not going to stop they're not
going to stop they're out there and they
should be but why do you think people
forget these things like all of these
details
the the BM riots I I don't think they
forget I think the issue is Democrats
don't know and don't care uh I'm going
to use Marian Williamson as a good
example I heard she just dropped out
recently too uh I don't know if that's
she I think I think she may have you
want to check but um Maran Williamson is
a is is a lovely woman she's very nice
she's very smart but she's unfortunately
living in Wawa world where she wants to
Department Of Peace doesn't she well
yeah when when when when we had her here
and we said here is a bad thing that is
happening she goes oh my that is so bad
I say here's another bad thing we're
concerned about goes wow I didn't know
that was happening wow when you show her
hey here's news like for example there's
a book called not my idea which is being
given to children in public schools
where it depicts white people a white
person as a devil offering you a
whiteness contract she nearly cried when
she saw it the issue with Marion
Williamson and many default liberals is
they are they are being manipulated by
demonic I mean that figuratively some
might mean it literally propagandists
and they're not aware of what's going on
now you said why don't do people forget
or not remember all of us remember all
of it she's still in she's still in oh
okay I apologize uh all of us remember
all of this stuff and we talk about it
all the time and we'll be on the show
and I'll say remember when this happened
remember when that happened it's that
people like Maryann and her followers
are never exposed to it in the first
place thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net
for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time